gang christmas came early this year
cause the are you garbage special is on
youtube right now yeah guys go share
with your friends hit them up in the
group chat tell people who aren't
familiar with the show this is a perfect
way to introduce them check it out it's
a good time a lot of laughs thanks for
watching love ya welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage take two it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out they're growth
to be classy yeah or they're just a big
old piece of trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful day we're down here at
anthony's basement she's skiing really
in the bathroom
real bogart with the bag too i'll tell
you that right now running the slalom up
there right here my carlos is coming at
you from across the table so you know
what that means it's just a fam tonight
damn damn he is the ceo of ru garbage
international businessman and i'm
starting to think part owner in the
brixton shirt company cause he's got 17
of them i got a lot of shirts this guy
give it up for kj
everybody hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are throw to roof through
the roof and then obviously patreon.com
you sign up you get a bunch of bonus
content i mean i feel like an [ __ ]
saying is two times a week every week
for the past year bonus content episodes
ayg hard feelings the breakaway hit hard
feelings um
and then live streams that we do every
month with the top tier members and then
also guys the a y g
comedy extravaganza
the
special inspection the soup of the day
streaming on the youtube page whatever
you want we got it over there go check
it out it's a 30 minute uh you know kind
of tour like 30 minute performance tour
it's it's uh
five cities i think
five of our favorite cities from the
tour mm-hmm shauna c houston new york
philly cleveland boston basketball
it was a good time so check it the [ __ ]
out it's on there share with your
[ __ ] friends someone posted on reddit
let's get this thing cooking there you
go i like to hear it i wanted to ask you
what did you realize um sean combs just
rebought back uh
uh sean john
rebought back he bought back to his
company really yeah i didn't know he had
sold it yeah
7.5 million i just want to know if you
heard that news and you were
you know in billionaire weekly no i
haven't been reading it what are you
talking about
i want other moguls yeah when are you
going to start getting into the
would that be the next move the clothing
line this is gonna somehow you want
t-shirts for free or something i'm sure
uh you wanna have an employee discount
my mom needs a new shower curtain
hopefully you get into bathroom fixtures
no i'm done with consumer goods i think
i did all that i did all the card games
i did all that all that [ __ ] i made i
made all of it from front to back
product design i came up with the i
remember asking you hey send me 20
questions for the car you would i
thought i asked you to check your
prostate you gave me such a what kind of
what do you want a card game meanwhile
you're cashing the checks on another so
it's all crypto and nfts going forward
for you what about the meadows
are you involved in that the the what is
it the what is the internet 3.0 that's
like the new thing right i got to get on
there i gotta get a screen name
i gotta lock that down i gotta i i gotta
get that kevin ryan on the new internet
get my profile pic on there
lane lay some claim how about a big
shout out to the magic man speaking of
the are you garbage comedy special
special specials the brains behind the
operation give it up for t-bone
mcstuffins toby mcbuggins what up dudes
no no we don't want to do that so what
we need to get into is licensing we need
like the ayg cornballer infomercial
running around three three o'clock in
the morning i like that what's a
cornballer
besides foley
i know what a cornball is you'll think
this is trashy when i was a kid around
christmas my uncles used to give us they
were they were called corn balls they
were popcorn balls that were like stuck
together with like toffee and [ __ ] like
that oh yeah i never [ __ ] with that i
was the i was the blue tin three the
cheese the the caramel and the rags
we're friends right i always left the
caramel till the end my fat ass tore
through the cheese then the butter
and then i'd go looking around probably
eat all the goldfish all the pretzels
out of the other cabinet and then go
back and eat that [ __ ] caramel in one
sitting you
do that was breakfast
there was snow boots in there by lunch
oh yeah holy [ __ ] um
i thought of this what i might have
mentioned this before but um this is
more i'm being vulnerable here i'm
telling you uh garbage wise i'm starting
to get to the point of fatness where i'm
becoming
eating around other people i'm becoming
aware of it okay i don't know if you
guys are because we've had shared a
couple meals over the last couple of
months i'm aware but like sometimes i'll
do something that i think someone's
looking at and i'm like oh my god they
must be ready to throw up
you know what i mean like no i have no
idea some please keep going
out of my mouth
the way my fork looks or how i mix
everything together i feel like have you
caught anything like that i feel like a
horse pulling a carriage when i'm eating
with you i got blinders on dude i just
look down at my plate i don't i catch
some shrapnel from you from time to time
piece of coleslaw flies out so you
try to keep your eyes away from because
if you if you didn't if you did see
something you might not want to see it
might turn it might turn you off yeah
you're also
a talker when you're eating
so there's things that are flying you
got you catch you catch some floaters
get this guy the tuna couple
couple of asteroids flying out of there
um plus we tried to get you on the the
mob boss uh napkin tuck in the shirt
here's the problem with that and you get
embarrassed about it and then you take
it out then you [ __ ] shirt up because
not everywhere we go is cloth napkins if
you took me to a nice joint i could use
a cloth napkin that's different i can't
be sitting there with a regular napkin
unfolded on my chest they're not a fun
it looks like a bad necktie you're not a
fun
guy to eat with it's a lot of time
because you feel it yeah oh yeah man you
can cut it with a butter knife
it's nobody touched the last button yeah
it's always
yeah at least my interpretation i could
be wrong there's always a quick [ __ ]
when you spill something on you so
that's not like a fun time to be [ __ ]
like
as as they're dropping the appetizers i
worry about those hot sticks are coming
out in the expl you know you're already
cursing everybody
i worry about that with my girl like i
ask you like do we like do you feel
comfortable when we eat together or do
you feel like rushed or feel like i'm
gonna i'm gonna get done mine and then
start eating yours
poor woman
she's probably starving over there know
you're [ __ ] stealing it all for fork
and [ __ ]
well i i think i think you know we
talked about bringing a financial
advisor in here for the patreon we got
it let's get somebody in here i want to
get like a teacher how to eat an
etiquette
yeah slow
i mean i don't know you know yeah no
there's there is a lot of two uh
one of my favorite things about eating
with you oh really well i mean it's it's
my favorite
cat
you're a very uh the delusional way that
i order where i think i'm making the
right choices oh well i mean there's
that i've i'm done even like trying to
put in like a hey why don't you just
give me two bottles did you not get the
three racks you know why why are you
leaving it at two give me two bottoms of
the buns i think that's a little bit
less bread
um
no it's like the fact of
you'll do the hey
i
you
you're aware that you're a bigger guy
and you don't want to have i feel like
everyone's looking at me i feel like
when i walk into the restaurant
everywhere i got to move the table
everyone's like that guy shouldn't put a
piece of food in his mouth no it's not
like that
uh i mean maybe i don't know if i saw if
i didn't know you and you walked into
the steakhouse
i figured they were gonna brand you or
something
call peta
um
you do the and it's it's one of my
gripes with you as a whole instead of
just saying i want this last p you got
to put on a big
show like we're all
you you think we all buy your horseshit
when no it's like literally talking to
like it's like talking to my nephew
really yeah everybody sees through me
dude
there'll be like one bite of like let's
say one mozzarella stick or one piece of
crab cake left and you're like oh toby
that's all you i don't even want that i
couldn't put another piece in me you
push the plate away throw the fork down
i'm duck i get a dog i don't even i'm
washing the plate
then you're going kippy and then t-bones
go now i'm going to say i i had the i
had the calamari and then and then you
go kippy that's you you take it then kim
you talking no i don't want you big man
no no no no no
foley just have it i don't want to
really all right we get it and then dude
by like the second time i push back it's
already in your mouth i'm not even
finished talking yet
it's a big it's a big [ __ ] you know
it's all smoke and mirrors i gotta
retrain my whole brain i know which i'm
happy for i'm happy you're you know are
we getting somebody in here let's get a
finishing lady in here or something okay
because i can look like a lady what i'm
doing they're very expensive i looked
into it really yeah i looked into like
some like personal etiquette coaches
that come in and give us like you know
how to have like a proper how to eat at
a dinner and we would you know we'd set
this as like a [ __ ] whatever i like
that but it's very expensive give me a
number
thousands of dollars wow that's not
happening yeah no not at all if i can't
get it for two trillion it ain't
happening tough break fellas put your
sunglasses on next time we're out to
dinner
gang family yep we're here we're
together mm-hmm uh which is what matters
it's all that matters this holiday
season this is coming up between
christmas and
new year's no man's land what are your
thoughts on that what that week between
christmas and new year's pretty sure we
talked about this in the episode we
recorded yesterday but yeah we could
retouch on it
pretty sure yeah yeah it's like no man's
land you don't know what's happening you
don't have pants on for a lot i don't
you know good movie week yeah it's good
like on the couch the tree's still up
the presents are still kind of scattered
around there's some [ __ ] some some
wrapping paper float a lot of cookies on
the kitchen table or whatever it's crazy
how quick that tree gets old right yeah
it's like the first what day do you dump
it
huh i would say
by the third it's gotta gotta get
skedaddle out february right
april yeah that thing yeah
feel real gross after that like you did
something wrong get it out of there i
know i'm like dreading taking it down
because then it's like when you're doing
it it's fun it's yeah this you got the
music playing it's the beginning of the
thing but [ __ ] needles are everywhere
i know but then you're like gotta make
sure you wrap up the ornaments and those
gotta go in the box if the box doesn't
call it's like [ __ ] me dude yeah it's
[ __ ] i look i'm thinking i'm gonna
i'm thinking i'm gonna have covet again
when that happens
hey sorry i got 20. it's weird yeah all
right uh guys it is a it is a family
episode so when you join patreon we will
answer your garbage question on air it's
just the best way to do it we get a [ __ ]
ton of requests from email dms
everything and uh the patreons just get
the first crank ate it
this one speaking of food speaking of
eating speaking of etiquette look at
that perfect transition look at that
it's pulling his strings back here uh
this is from nicholas long never had a
question read when you're taking the
first bite of a burger
slash fcs fried chicken sandwich i guess
that is i'm putting that together on the
fly so and placing it back down on the
plate right can you put yourself there
oh yeah
there already the glory days uh and
placing it back down on plate do you
place the burger upside down or right
side up it's a thinker to imagine but
upside down is garbage i think i'm an
upside down guy depending on the
structure of this always
it's because it's then it's easier your
thumbs are listen not everything like a
backhoe not every sandwich is built the
same no you're sometimes it's a [ __ ]
high-wire act
they did i don't get the shot i'm like i
look at the chef like have you ever
eaten a burger why are you giving this
to how am i supposed to you got the
towel if you need to stick a [ __ ]
steak knife through it it's not going to
hold it with an arrow yeah
what did my [ __ ] scooby doo over here
yeah dude it's brutal then the bun
starts falling apart you gotta go upside
down you gotta lay that you gotta lay it
down like prop it against the fries or
something yes
yeah it's like a game of jenga and it's
it's just easier that way because then
you have it you come up one boom and
down that's how you do it toby zoom in
on this somebody said i love whenever
kippy says zoom in toby never zooms in
toby make sure you're not to zoom in we
don't have the technology
i'll say this usually if i'm alone
i mean i only put my burger down for the
sake of the other people in the room oh
you'll
dude that's that's my biggest beef about
burritos
you've been telling me this for years
once you pick it up you're committed no
you can do it no
okay
can't okay same thing with a bet with it
with a sloppy burger i just keep it in
my hand and i go bite sip bite sip bite
sip i'm gonna go fry i go right hand on
the fry okay hold my burger in my hand
there's something so trashy about
holding a burger with one hand to me
it's so unrefined
it's so
sideways yeah it's
it's
uh the grease dripping into your palm
then that smell don't come off for a few
three days
burger grease
i don't care what kind of soap you got
yeah if you're reaching for more food
while you're chewing that's [ __ ] up
i'm huge with that i like to have that
it's it's it's all the different things
in my mouth at the same time
same way in college
[Laughter]
same way in the
bedroom absolutely
that's the way i like it i like every
little thing
together
all in there partying together you got
the bite of the burger and you the
satisfaction of the fries sip of the
root beer
yeah i eat quick right i
it's like uh
when everything's dropped it's going i'm
doing the fries for a little bit to let
the burger cool down i can wrap my head
around the best strategy to get am i
going upside down what am i doing so why
are you giving me a hard time about the
apps and stuff like that it should be
free-flowing should be a no judgement
zone it's a foley what's
looking at do you think i do do you
think in some reality i know you don't
want that last point to crap so next
time that we go out today just take it i
don't care that's what i'm gonna do yeah
next time you go out to dinner i mean
all the appetizers you still act like we
just met this is like our fur like you
know what i mean like oh i'm gonna be
polite actually called me a jerk off two
minutes ago like we're in a business
lunch yeah that's exactly how you treat
it
you flipping between like arch nemesis
and like new guy at the office hey i
don't have the last cake and pizza you
[ __ ] jerk off i'm like what the i
don't know i don't know what i don't
know what foley i'm getting i'm trying
to go over the regional numbers with you
yeah yeah yeah oh you take it yeah just
take it i don't give a [ __ ] that's every
man for himself nice i when i do take
the last thing i go i'm taking this i'm
going you know i'll let it sit if nobody
makes a move
i'm just going all right that's that's
after three minutes i'm going at it so
you're telling me in most situations i'm
i've been lying to myself like i just
had a meal with my my girl you've been
lying to yourself for 45 years
that's been working
[Laughter]
american company right there
um i just had a meal with uh what you
know the social meal with people
breakfast with people so they're so they
know that all too okay that's what i'm
you're telling me that they all see
through it too
i don't know uh
i should just be an animal then
get up on the table
i don't know
oh you're saying the people you just had
dinner with does everybody see this
not just you
i think that's hobie gets it you get i
mean it's it's also all right so there's
two foleys there's that foley who
most
people on the outside circle get
the nice guy the have the last crab cake
guy
then there's
what i would call the real foley the
ocean miser
it was a dark twisted man
and then you try to hide that guy only
leave the shells yeah um no yeah i i
just think i like i get insulted i'm
like in what world do you think i don't
i think you don't want that last
mozzarella stick like i want it if i
want it you definitely wanted you what i
offered to you why don't you say you can
have it because i'm my i got to buy you
know something i'm watching my figure i
got the steak on something and it's fun
to watch you squirm yeah i like i like
to watch your taff dance a little bit i
might have it i don't know
yeah yes sure you guys don't want it i'm
not sure maybe let's just leave it for a
couple of minutes
why i want it to look in the eyes for
the next three minutes i might take it
to go to go
that's a piece of [ __ ] wrap it up here
i'm going to take it off i can have it
tomorrow for lunch wrapping up apps
you're a bastard oh yeah
go away
um
yeah just take it just take it okay also
no that's behind us now we're not gonna
be doing apps and stuff like that
anymore in the world yeah yeah yeah i
know about it
um
yeah upside you got to go upside down
with the burgers you know if you're a
chef out there tighten up the burger
game a little bit some of they're just
nuts sometimes you can't make sure make
sure the buns have enough elastic
elasticity that's going to keep
everything in play yeah and i'll tell
you what right now lettuce tomato and
onion i'm starting to get to the point
where that can kick rocks i i'm a big i
don't know
i'll i'll definitely go this is me
uh raw onions i don't [ __ ] with so but
if it's just onion roll onions so the
old guy's saying i know i want it well
done with raw onion tivoli comes with
lettuce tomato or like pickles or
whatever i'll say no tomato if it's
listed i'll keep the lettuce but then
when i get it i'll put eyes on the
lettuce and sometimes they give you like
a real jerk-off piece of it it looks
like it was underwater for four [ __ ]
days
yeah it looks like seaweed i'm gonna get
out of here with that i want like a
crisp i don't want some soggy ass jaws
but they put the lettuce and tomato in
the to-go container with the burger and
the fries ruined
wilt oh yeah all that weird lettuce
in there no no no no no no no no no no
no no yeah i want to taste the farmland
let's [ __ ] do it
i'm not doing that
um all right home run of a question by
the way getting a lot done here solving
a lot of the world's problems that's why
people tune in how do you eat a burger
you choose um
this is from zachary love the special
ah
let's see i thought it was the other day
do you pronounce the word often o f t e
n as off 10 like often or often
i would say i say often
does it often i do often i often yeah
how often do you go often often no tea
in that for me nah often
i got a t in there
often yeah you're a little you would you
do have a little bit of like the
southern like uh proper you know
gentlemen think with that
[ __ ] like that what i say aunt and [ __ ]
like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah folks like that type
of thing yeah weird you are
theoretically from the south but
not theoretically it's where i got
[ __ ] out yeah south of bozo is that
where you were born in north carolina
weed yes damn i didn't know he was born
he is southern
yeah you're a weird southern kid you
know that yes
wouldn't cut it on the ranch i can't
think of that much blowing up frogs with
them 80s and stuff
where was the lab you were born in
um
i'm off i'm that's what i'm realizing
obviously we speak so much on [ __ ]
michael it's you know between the
patreon it's four episodes of [ __ ]
week patreon.com um people really pick
up on my dirt bag
northeast white trash lingo like the
vodka
vodka
uh off it yeah it's like it's a really
it's it's
i'm embarrassed by it
to an extent asking a half drunk chicken
philly at a bar what kind of shot you're
under a vodka
even that dude i'm embarrassed by it
embarrassed yeah embarrassed
embarrassed embarrassed oh no
embarrassed embarrassed what is it
what's the real one embarrassing fairest
embarrassed get the [ __ ] out of here do
you say tomato as well
i'm not communist what are you talking
about this is america all right
hey why don't you take your schedule and
kick rocks yeah are you in the queue
right now what's happening
kids when you were young and you like to
get tuned up you said sometimes step
over the line didn't you but now that
you're older mature and you have some
responsibilities you're just looking for
a nice mellow kickback reach for dad
grass
when you're reaching for your goodies
after work dad grass is legal organic
smokable hemp that relaxes the body
mellows the mind 100 percent organic
pre-rolled joints very low thc very high
cbd nice you enjoy the effects to save
day all while keeping your head clear
yeah it's a gentleman's move it's like
getting
you know it's chill out without getting
stoned have a glass of wine not the
whole bottle i love that line that's a
great line of coffee perfect let you
know exactly what you're getting into
all that grass products are federally
legal for all ages 18 and over
uh and it ships right to your door
anywhere in the u.s of a yeah uh right
now dadgrass is offering our listeners
20 off your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com garbage go to dadgrass.com
garbage for 20 off your first order one
more time write it down sing it from the
rooftops that's
garbage do it do it can't let's talk
about black buffalo love black buffalo
let's talk about an alternative
to dipping yeah to chew which is gross
pouches long cut lose it kick rocks i
say black buffalo is the way to go
follow the buffalo yeah it's it's
everything you love about it like that
it's everything you love about dipping
including pharmaceutical grade nicotine
just without the actual tobacco or stem
edible green leaves food grade
ingredients this is what we're talking
about and only if you're over 21. yeah
no kids yeah with the same flavors
textures aroma pack and nicotine as
traditional tobacco products no
compromise required my favorite thing
about these black buffalo boys and gals
made in the usa i'm talking born in the
midwest raising the south some good old
boy
yeehaw
slapping international proudly
manufactures their products right here
in the god dang us of a
uh they sent us some i've dabbled you
know i'm trying to get off the bernies
and everything you gotta look this is a
great this is a great alternative it's a
move it's a fantastic the right time a
lot of dippers out there i know that
very much right time right place to make
a move yes uh so if you're one of the 10
million people who are 21 and over in
dip tobacco consider turning over a new
leaf
and switching to black buffalo it's
everything you love about dipping just
without the actual tobacco leaf or stem
head to blackbuffalo.com use promo code
garbage at checkout for 25 off your
first order two five 25 percent that's
the best offer you're gonna find use our
promo code garbage for 25 off your first
order one last time garbage promo code
garbage for 25 off your first order
gotta tie it as warning this product
contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical now
fall above schedule is pretty classy
schedule let me check my schedule yeah
it's nice
[Music]
how the europeans spell color too
they'll throw you off oh with the u and
flavor what the f they got a u in there
don't they
yeah and in theater they swap the r and
the e and the e in the r yeah
it's
gentlemen
yeah all right let's see this is uh from
your new uncle never had a question read
is it garbage to put coffee spelled
wrong and bailey's in an empty starbucks
cup to walk around with it or is that
just a life hack
that's a life hack
that's why you're not driving you got to
saturday off if you're doing some [ __ ]
with the kids
you think it's okay
that's what we're doing these cold
winter months my family calls uh
there's certain family members you see
walking around with a wawa cup post noon
that's known as an afternoon coffee i
would never i would not there's
there's no coffee in it i would never
think of how many people out there when
i see them with coffee cups have booze
in it that's never even been entered my
mind but i imagine it's probably
a higher percentage that's a lot of
construction workers
construction workers booze like yeah
heavy i know heavy
lunchtime i could never do it because
rain opera's coming right coming into
the bar and having a liquid lunch
jesus
[ __ ] swinging the ball around 57th
street
taking out the met like they're playing
tetherball yeah i don't get it i've
never had that at work i can't even do
it in comedy really
the booze like fall asleep yeah it's
either like i got two it's either on
full [ __ ] throttle boozing and that's
what we're doing we're boozing we got
the bernie's there's nothing slowing me
down i don't have any responsibilities
i'll have like when we do our shows i'll
take like one on state one or two on
like as the show starts i'll have one or
whatever sure but that's it
but yeah to like
because i don't want to like have to do
something drunk i can't it slows
everything down for me i get all that
heavy head
like work a wet saw in the 20s on the
23rd floor of an unfinished high rise
yeah no [ __ ] some of those guys are just
building a few drinks and go window
washing yeah some of those guys are just
[ __ ] built different for sure
but i would say in that situation what
no it's good people bailey's little
coffee go for a while i think it depends
or whatever you know yeah by all means i
don't give a [ __ ] also i mean maybe you
got a job where you're like maybe you're
built you're bullied to the like
constructions wonky but if you're you
work some sort of job like by yourself
in some stock room or something and
you're like hey i like to
have a little happy hour typing
then you're just drinking in the stock
room that's bad news i mean what the
[ __ ] the difference i've drank in
worse places in the stock room getting
paid for it drinking in a broom closet
nah you're good you're living your life
i used to get tuned up when i was a dog
walker
yeah dude
dirt bag
on the people's liquor
what
yeah
no
sure
wasn't bringing his own [ __ ] hooch
the good [ __ ]
[Laughter]
glenn levitt 18 round one
hanging out with the shih tzu on western
avenue take sparky out for a dump
[Laughter]
jesus christ
[Laughter]
this one's a [ __ ] home run this is
from braxton marshall is it garbage to
use is it garbage to use kippy and foley
as a business reference on a job
application if you're a 20 member
for
the patreons out there you have to be a
card carrying patreon i will say you're
an employee of the show if you need me
to
i will be a proper reference for you who
was your three references uh when you
were applying for jobs like high school
and college of course it was uh
i would put my mom down a lot because it
was a different last name oh nice so
that well that always you know not
previous employment did you know they
asked for reference personal references
yeah yeah i always put down pat's mom
nice shout out to mrs mrs uh mrs s
always did it i don't think i think she
got one or two calls you know she would
be like yeah sometimes she would lie you
know what i mean like yeah he was like
the ceo or whatever he's supposed he's
fluent in 12 languages
like kevin we hear you speak swahili
like it was for an apartment what are we
doing here uh it's not med school honey
it was always pat's parents for sure
uh my mom or my stepdad because of
different last names and typically like
an aunt with a different last name like
aunt patty or something well you're a
better man than me we we we never left
anything like that to chance we always
went directly to each other i would put
down my buddy jackson my buddy kramer my
buddy seth we would all put each other
but they know they're talking to
do they yeah they do also too it's like
if i put my aunt down and somebody calls
me because you know kevin ryan she's not
gonna be like yeah that cocktail grows
me 20 bucks she's gonna cause she's
gonna react favorably yeah we always
told each other
he [ __ ] calls oh we've done that for
sure too yeah yeah the one time i was
this was uh has anyone ever had real
references what if anyone i don't know
who that would be yeah an old boss who i
left or i got fired yeah like what do
you miss her pit i don't know
who he is i know are you friends with
any wealthy people i don't i don't get
it
the one time i was getting my first
apartment in new york city by myself
first one bedroom apartment
um
i was living with my boy
and i was just paying him like 600 bucks
a month cash
and it was his apartment
and i had no i hadn't been on a lease
in like i don't know seven years or
eight years or something like that
so they asked for like rental history
and i'm like i got
i've been i'm like do venmo work you
know transactions like i got nothing so
i had my boy rent started in 1842
he did a book report on it
[Laughter]
history on the musical
um
it was a good play um so
i was on i was he was like you make
just enough this is when i was working
at that wall like that good law firm so
i made just enough money i qualified on
my own
for rent control department
and
he was like i need
i was like trying to get it and i was
like is there anything i can do i can
give you uh
a letter from my current landlord
that says like i've nev because my rent
my credit sucked he's like your credit
it was like a 535 or he's like i you
know everything tells me not to to rent
this to you and i'm like i'll i'll give
you uh i'm like it was student loans
that [ __ ] me up everything tells me
nothing
i mean your credit report they're like
anybody that's ever given this guy's
money he's never paid us back that
doesn't mean that's a couple of dings
these credit scores oh buddy we're
hijacked by them it's not who we are as
people i was way pat no it's
they're my credit score
three years ago is an identical
reflection of me as a human for sure hey
zip it you want the apartment or not
kind of putting a good word for this guy
shooting himself in there
i'm a piece of [ __ ] yeah oh for sure
i'm just getting my [ __ ] together and my
credit score is going up but i want you
know i'll probably be on time every
month
i might have to keep some plates we
might have to hold that check to like
the seventh or something
um
how are you with being cool
how do you guys define grace period
they don't i don't even start thinking
about the check till the first of the
month
you're not getting my money before it's
due okay jerk off do you
put the first on a check that you
actually write on the fifth i don't even
have checks i if i have to get a check i
go to the bank and pay with a bank check
for eight bucks
that's i'll try i don't i haven't had
checks in well over a decade i was
paying my my rent was paid cash the
whole time i lived in new york you don't
have a checkbook we've we talked about
you know a checkbook i got a couple
couple checkbooks i got starter
different names or what's the deal you
got mickey mouse checks i know they give
you like blank checks when you like i
open up the company account
like we don't have the company doesn't
have a checkbook it's all done online
ach payments give me your bank banking
full routing hit me with a router
hit me up coming down the bike
yeah it's all vemmo and zell you a zell
guy the hell's that i know i had to get
it somebody paid us in zill or something
yeah it's like it's enough already with
this yeah it's a good venomous paper
that's like a venmo for business kind of
gentlemen um i don't [ __ ] with it we got
it though so if anybody see anybody
wants to pay gazelle hit me up
um finders fee but i had my roommate
the guy was my roommate essentially not
my landlord i had my roommate that's a
hookup make a fake but on paper made a
fake like you know
corporation yeah johnny enterprises inc
you know whatever whatever kevin has
paid his rent for the past seven years
here blah blah blah never been late
always late
[Laughter]
um always late
and i sent it to my boss or my boss i
sent it to the potential landlord he
goes did your buddy just make this or
something i'm like nah man i swear to
god it's a real guy dude he's all right
through it he goes what is this you were
staying at your buddy's place and paying
him rent i'm like ah no sir written in
cram yeah so it was it was all cut out
from a magazine
half blue ink half black ink
yeah it was bad but now i got my life
together credit score is going up that's
you know that's how they gauge your uh
iq car insurance as well for your credit
a lot of play i think they stopped it
but for a long time that's what they
were doing there's like a direct
correlation of how bad of a driver you
are versus your credit payment what yeah
your credit score holy [ __ ] i think it
is an underlying thing of like
yes guys you know you're probably
getting high not paying your bills and
crashing your cars what's happening
[ __ ] smoking the chiva
popping eddies
no i crashed my car and then i got high
to get over there had a license you've
never had a like they're at a license
you've never driven a car ever
no no no i've driven cars and [ __ ] like
that yeah but never had a license never
had a permit
you're gonna go your whole life without
a license your parents wouldn't get
married
[Music]
you into adulthood with without
teaching you how to drive
you can swim right
yeah excellent swimmer
like a fish gotta be can't drive
anywhere how do you think i get to work
every day
how do you think i cross the hudson
river
is there a channel or an inlet around
here
yeah you gotta look for waterways when
you're looking for new apartments
[ __ ] aqua kid over here what's the
dock situation around the apartment
a lot of krill laying around
can i bring my own caliper
how is that possible man
dude i don't because i've never knew you
there's been like two how were you
getting around as as a young man i don't
know was your mom like dropping you off
at a bar or your friend's house when you
were like in your 20s
i didn't live with my parents in my 20s
because i'm not a loser like you
this guy there i'm a man i'm a man who
loves his mother
and drives her car
[Laughter]
i went to boarding school then i went
straight to chicago and rode your 10
speed around
six speed gear dude no single speed
single speed i don't even know what any
of that means sounds bozo
um all right this one is directed at
toby a little bit i would thought it was
going to go to the big man but you're
really getting it today mention t-bone
uh let's see
this is from matthew this sounds like a
t-bone thing never have one read you
ever make your own fish tacos at a taco
bell long john silver's combo
drive-through so i guess you order a
taco and some sort of fish from long
john silver and combine them
no i'm not a seafood guy but i have
that's right kfc taco bell i have stuck
a a tender and a taco it's [ __ ]
awesome shout out to the slash it's
pretty good yeah
you
i'm not a i'm not a big fan of the of
the of this of the the combos yeah
something about it just doesn't feel
right yeah first time i walked into a
traditional list sometimes i first time
i walked into a dunkin donuts
baskin-robbins i was like oh this ain't
good
this is this is how it starts
and it has all gone down the hill from
there
yeah they cut the flavors down the guy
making the donuts doesn't know how to do
the ice cream either either they want to
do one or the other either they're real
good at the ice cream when they stick in
the doughnuts i feel like the ice cream
is always like a proper afterthought at
a dunk it at a dunkin 100 that's not
their money they're like i don't where's
the scooper yeah johnny took it home
with them they're giving you [ __ ] you're
missing the nerds the style we're out of
the whip
yeah yeah yeah i'm doing a cop it's also
like [ __ ] jerk off yeah i get it but
i mean there's yeah that's why i just go
i just get an ice cream cake whenever i
go out now let's get a full cake
shut up
at the grocery store can you put happy
day fat ass on this
happy day happy day
happy
days not even trying to hide it
here you go lordys could you write
wednesday on that please
but sarah it's thursday i know i missed
yesterday i was sick
that reminds me of like a place i like
the place in order for tomorrow i need a
thursday friday too you guys open on
sunday you do church hours
[Laughter]
what are you just for me um
this one's from kyle never had a
question right is it garbage to floss
your teeth with beard hair right which
is like what the [ __ ] the most
disgusting thing to me what are you
wolverine how [ __ ] is your beard hair
just the thought of it gives me the eb
use your fingernail
dude always
oh i leave it i leave it on there so i
have a little handle
it's like seeing the hygienist i didn't
know you were in the dentistry
weird hobby to have beard hair yeah
that's [ __ ] insane dude
you find a hair in your food are you
done
home cooked never at the restaurant
i think we've talked about this it
depends on
length color where it is on the plate if
i can
how many [ __ ] manhattans i've had
lengths in color
get eight feet eight feet of gray i'm
out the door yeah
i have a little curly cue and i can tell
myself it's an arm hair that's one thing
i don't know it depends harm hair is
okay
i'd rather have hair hair
head hair
than arm hair ugh
i'm saying i don't know it's a pain it's
a really game time decision what about
what about my hair
huh
is it my tuesday cake
um
what's your hair on the toes situation
with youtube
i can imagine yours is bad
for the listener toby has the weirdest
toes in the world dude he has alien
fingers they're like they're longer than
my fingers
that's how he sets up the cameras
that's how he works he's reached this
three shot it's like he's part king crab
he's an uh opelia
those things man
yay couple dudes spider crabs i'm creepy
out too i don't [ __ ] with them i pulled
one of them up by accident one time as a
kid that got loose on the [ __ ] when
you go to like we go rent one of those
flat bottom boats with the little engine
in the back you go crabbing shout out to
north wildwood
somebody put up what i was described to
me as a spider crab and this dude
he was the captain dude he took over the
boat dude it was no longer i almost went
overboard because things are tall as
[ __ ] yeah they're high they're like
daddy longlegs of the sea dude no
no
cut the line wildwood crabbing sounds
like a rough night with a tugboat on the
boardwalk
been there
fog rolling in
[Laughter]
uh tickle t-bone's fancy um
that's great dude
looking at a group of jigs walking into
a bar and saying fog rolling in
it's so mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
my toes my toe situation is
nice
yeah i'm not a hairy guy
yeah either what are you talking about
yeah like robin williams i have a little
i have a little patch here
my pubes are all right
ass is bare
legs or whatever yeah i'm fine shaves
his ass though
i go to a specialist don't forget the
cheeks
i feel like j-lo back there uh
um
all right let's see this one's from ryan
does anyone in your family have a dirt
track race car number decal on their
personal vehicle to show support for a
family member that races
that's a very specific not on the door
says cool whip on your hood
big seven on the side you mean like a
little one i guess yeah well that yeah i
mean listen we it's it's well documented
any type of sticker
anything on a car is bad yeah racing's
tough too show support it's what we're
does imagining one once every six months
i'm a racing i come from a racing family
embarrassingly enough oh my my stepdad's
race car numbers are on everybody he's
not talking about nascar everybody or
formula oh he was in nascar for a little
back he made a run at it like he like
moved down to north carolina was in the
circuit trying to work his way up as a
driver as a driver yeah it's pretty
sweet uh i mean i think it was like a
couple of months and like he was just
still crapped out and he did he always
drove
he drove the car dirt track and then he
moved to
uh like modified like earnhardt cars we
were we were a big earnhardt family who
the [ __ ] was intimidator flags banners
the call like stickers on the cars we
were it was he was a [ __ ] badass yeah
shout out god damn it those cars back
then
we're just like regular cars
roll cage in it
yeah
uh
that's crazy he's a race car driver
yeah step that's a rate was a race car
he's a race car driver uh
you got to have some kind of nerve
to do that that's a different breeded
dude
he's a cowboy they're like they're like
somebody
you could just be an idiot don't know
what you're doing but if you know what
you're doing and you go out there and do
that [ __ ] yay but that's like i look at
it
they had a crew right they would like
tinker on the [ __ ] car all week or
whatever like the week leading up to the
race it was like yeah i gotta go down to
the shop get the wheels i gotta go out
to here do the whatevers
brian's meeting me there andy's meeting
me he had like a crew of the crew of
bozos
you're down there washing a tight pair
of shorts
i'm topless
that's where i saw my first set of
hooters
at the track no at the shop oh like on
that oh on the thing oh yeah the cutout
from a playboy on the [ __ ] tool chest
that's pretty good where's the first
place you saw a naked woman
it's pretty good i would love to see you
in a race car shop you got you got real
hey kid hold the light box oh
i got yelled at one time so bad
it's fat [ __ ] all the donuts again
this is christ the second thousand in
the morning
jerry you want to get this kid out of
here
[Laughter]
idiot yeah
nothing makes you feel like a loser when
you go to work with your dad as a kid
talk about feeling incompetent oh
man i would knock something over do
something stupid what'd i tell you
[Laughter]
he's got lollipops all over his files
can we stop at wawa again jesus christ
kid
how many pretzels do you need
dude i was a bit i went to work with my
dad all my dad dad all the time doing
nothing not when you worked there just
when you had no worries sometimes dude
like this is insane we would do like
shutdowns on like you know like big
build like shut down's like like a hotel
if they had to like change the [ __ ]
water heater yeah i got you they have to
shut the water down at like the hyatt
from two to four
i would go as like a nine-year-old and
just i don't i guess because he couldn't
get he wouldn't get a babysitter i'd be
in like the basement of like man if i
was the clown i like dude dude like the
maintenance might be looking like what's
this fat kid doing here
i was eating a bagel with cream cheese
at like three in the morning standing in
an elevator shaft
yeah
playing with transformers at the bottom
of the elevator
see all right down there yeah it'd be
good dad's like if anybody asks you say
you're an apprentice i'm like all right
gives you a fake inspector number
i had like a local jacket on and
everything
anybody asked tell me you're looking for
ron
it'll confuse them
get out in front of it
act like you've been there before
[Applause]
ron's still up to his old [ __ ] again
puts a little grease on your face
that and then he would go into it'd be
like me and my brother we were just with
him all the time you know we owned a
small business so we were just with like
if you own a small business out there
you know it's like you're working all of
the time like there was no like i'm the
babysitters we would just go we would he
would leave me and my brother in the car
for hours keys with the keys
and we would while we went in for like
job meetings or like walkthroughs or
whatever dude we would end up beating
the motherless [ __ ] out of each other in
a jeep cherokee like i'm talking choke
holds [ __ ] weapons getting out of the
car chasing locking each other out it
was mayhem two bermuda fish in a bank
parking lot oh yeah it was bad
it was bad i told you to put him in the
same bowl
he comes back you're missing half a tail
your brother's cut in half
his tail still moving though
dude it's like putting
same thing you guys are what four years
apart five years apart five years ago
being my brother two years apart you put
two three people in that situation
okay and then you disappear it's like
there's a timer the oxygen's running out
of the room it's gonna eventually turn
into a fight
radio this that [ __ ] you
yeah
dude add a little summer heat to that
too
yeah come on trying to put you're trying
to change the song put that on i said
put it on any changes to be a jerk off
that was a damn that was that was my
brother's patented move dude talk about
a powder keg uh dude i remember the one
time we were in a parking lot of like a
medical czechoslovakian 39. we were
waiting
we fought i mean
this is the problem with the pro the
issue with me and my brother is
obviously it's like the older brother he
would beat my ass but i was a big i was
a fat kid like i had power you know what
i mean and he was like a skinnier
regular sized kid he was like a guy
fighting a bear
fighting a bear cub
so we were like
the same size or like at least the same
mass a lot of the you know what i mean
like if i was if he was 12 i was the
size of a 12 year old so
i could get him i hung like a
three-year-old i still am
i could sting him at todd you know what
i mean like if i punched him or like i
could i could toss them or whatever i
found that when i was just pissed off oh
man that was bad
the mo if you checked if you checked him
at all oh it was like he turned it on
yeah [ __ ] hold your face
into the ground yeah that one good punch
was never worth it my brother would
stick my head into the cushions of the
couch
developed
developed a fear of claustrophobia from
it yeah i believe i've shared that with
you
sensitive dude foley you would you would
never survive on a real job site but
where you would shine is in the
cigarettes and coffee outside the job
site i feel like you would crush that
the roach coach what's this bozo talking
about i have survived on a job site i
wasn't at some fancy boarding school
drinking martinis with the chancellor's
daughter i was out working as a laborer
landscaper i was the [ __ ] job site
but yes
i was the job but yes i did shine at
lunchtime thank you
you're doing a monologue on the bench
yeah
i did have good banter with the with the
lunch lunch truck guy
big fan of that too i was like my dad's
a big fan of that too what uh we were
lunch truck people growing up if we
drove by a construction site and it was
lunch time we get out and get a couple
of dogs yeah couple dogs and some
chocolate milk we were big
uh
when i was when
as i got older obviously and like i was
working um i was seven at this time you
also called your dirtbag landscaping job
the the job site yeah you were you were
you were in charge of the weed whacking
this all right this guy's making that's
not act like you were a shop store this
guy's made his biggest like i never got
my hands dirty what are you talking
about
it was wing night
it's all in my face
they were all out of wet wipes it was my
nom i always had a manual labor job
always
this [ __ ] guy
except for the years you were working
we're selling cheap knick bags at
divorcees in fort lauderdale you're
giving me [ __ ]
you're long hair hippie
you're nuts
[Laughter]
this guy i really saw me like that i
know bring me over here
as uh as i'm in the union
the philadelphia union
big fan
shout out to them they had a great
season this year
they did they almost made the finals
they almost won the championship i
believe you that's fantastic i didn't
i didn't think you didn't believe me on
that um
i really sh i really love cause i was
low man on the totem pole obviously with
my dad my brother me so i was i was you
know the [ __ ] gopher [ __ ] i had to do
the coffee [ __ ] up the coffee order
coffee runs uh which i did enjoy i liked
knowing what everybody wanted type thing
you know what i mean when you figured it
out but i figured like i'd like even now
i went and got coffee before we recorded
today you said get toby's coffee i know
how toby takes his coffee you know what
i mean i like that i'm like yeah you
okay yeah but he's not gonna hit you
with a lug wrench if it's wrong
i said three splendas yeah um those guys
hands their construction hands they look
like they were their hands like thanos
brutal yeah big cracks in there don't
[ __ ] around just choke you with one hand
men manly men men real men back one not
us no
no no
um
yeah uh this is the same vein as the
brother stuff brother fighting this is
from james benson uh ever knife fight
with your friends when you were a kid or
teenager it was an actual knife i guess
i don't know it had a lot of likes on
the page when it was posted so i guess a
lot of people did it it's a west side
story jesus christ knife fight my buddy
we were not we were knife kids like
pocket knife i liked having a pocket
knife as a little bit i mean we were
like
woodsy people you know a little bit like
as kids when you've got nothing going on
in the suburbs we just [ __ ] go into
the woods and like a tree forward like
you're just [ __ ] around sure um yeah
i'm not trying to i'm not painting like
a [ __ ] huckleberry finn over here
you know what i mean um we were hanging
out like bike jumps and [ __ ] just kind
of [ __ ] whatever the way of the
samurai
[Laughter]
got the tweezers out on my swiss army
night
um
toothpick never worked those things
stunk yeah swiss army knives can kick
rocks also they were so big i'm like
yeah the [ __ ] it's like you had a pickle
in your pocket
the [ __ ] out of here yeah somebody's
trying to break down me like whoa this
is cool great you got a toothpick get
out of here um
still steal it though
uh
we cut my i think i might have told this
story my my friends snuck a
switchblade in from mexico
when they went down to mexico as kids
and they brought a switchblade a real
switch
heavy bike straight out the top you want
to talk about a classic piece of
american history those switchblade combs
man they'd get you laid those things
up your nose with a rubber hose i heard
he's banging the principal
mr greenland
um
my buddy had one i forget the exact how
this how the exact series of events
i don't know if i was holding it or not
but there was one i think i bought it
off my friend for like 10 bucks
and because like his mom's like you
can't keys i got he's like i can't take
this home like so i'm like i'll buy it i
bought it like 10 bucks
i think no one gives a [ __ ] at your
house oh it was wide open i was a knife
i was like i was a collector right
behind glass yeah no you're joking what
you put them behind glasses no no no i
just had like three pocket knives weird
kid yeah i was a weird kid
man i needed them for the job site how
am i gonna open boxes
i feel like you would have had those
like this really lame one that the kids
always have that look like change colors
basically it's like purple and green i
do that's exactly what i picture that is
it's exactly what i pictured when you
said behind glass you can see like the
metal work in it like it has like waves
in it almost no
it's like [ __ ] that like dudes in hot
topic would have exactly so you want to
see something oh i think i know what you
mean it's like it's like it's like it's
almost like oily like the way it's like
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no no no no no had a
butterfly knife
like pocket yeah i don't know i was like
10 i guess i don't know
you never cut what are you doing with
this
are you pulling this on anybody
protecting his virginity what do you
think
get away from
me uh
no i wasn't pulling it on anybody what
are you talking about
you must have thought you were so cool
little fat kid a sweatsuit
um little bowl cut
knocked you out
[ __ ] hey you were 12 years older than
me
be weird if you if you were 20 beating
up a 12 year old
um
oh that's funny how what am i 10 years
older than you yeah so i was 10. so
definitely definitely at a certain point
i could have beat you and danny up
i know danny would have been
he would have been 16. so only four
years apart yeah you guys would have
took me yeah and i was the size of a 42
year old at the time
i had a pension and home
um but maybe when i was he's nuts too
hold on so when i was 15 he was 10
and i was five oh that's how i got yours
then yeah that's not fair that's what i
gotta go back in time to
t-bone set it up what year is this 87
[ __ ]
um that was one
sorry i get you go back and kill baby
kippy
if you could if you had a time machine
would you go back and kill baby kippy
before this ever got started
you somehow fight them off resist don'ts
i start swinging my head around
taking people out
taking out the troops
how tough of a look would that be what i
get beat up by a 15 year old and a 10
year old
not the face like scott farkas kicking
my ass who this christmas story uh i was
thinking seinfeld he had his little
buddy with him um that's good
all right we gotta do one or two more
here and then we got a rip bear up this
has been a hum dinghy um
wait there was just something else that
i wanted to [ __ ] say
ah [ __ ] i forget it um
this one is from anthony shout out to
aunt anthony is it trashy to cheat on an
exam and what were your techniques
man
this is going to take a minute
if i put as much effort into studying as
you did cheating that's the that's the
old you know as old as time um
that would depend
usually i would rely
on the human element okay human i would
get to somebody
or
i would know i would figure it out over
the couple a couple of weeks
if i was nice to somebody who was smart
or friends with somebody that's smart
get next to him usually you're walking
around the school dressed up like a
janitor trying to get the inside scoop
miss lippy's car is green
[Laughter]
talking while i'm not looking at
somebody yeah you guys going to the game
tomorrow
[Laughter]
now you well usually most people were
pretty cool about it like the smart kids
in my school most of them especially as
we got older they didn't give a [ __ ]
they would just literally put their
paper close to you and just
boom and just knock it out
that's the that's the best way right to
the source yeah the best way
i've done the writing on the hand yeah
all that [ __ ] also too i'll be honest
with you
it got to a certain point where i wasn't
really covering it up too well the
writing was on the wall sure especially
as
not to bring up the glory days that was
your cheating technique all the answers
are on the wall
[Laughter]
as as as the sports progressed in high
school
it was there was a lot more leniency
i'll be honest with you as far as what i
did academically and
i just didn't care
sure so yeah yeah it was kind of like
that
i mean every once in a while just to
dust off the skills i you know
just for fun yeah shits and gigs yeah it
was really for them not for me
i just give the kids a show i wanted to
know what i thought one of my parents
and i was at least trying yeah you know
so i i'd go dirty again yeah what about
you
there was a lot i was uh
also you know
fake arms
rolling in a wheelchair
i got dummy legs on
fake noses and mustaches baby
where's that greek man taking kevin's
test i was always you know uh
pretty i was always smart enough and had
a decent enough grasp to get by hated
those kids just like i'm gonna get a c
and if i do i'm like i can get a c on
anything for the most part right
not me with a little bit of
understanding of what's happening but in
that moment if i would get the test and
i realized i'm a little hemmed up i
start p.e yeah you start peeking around
or whatever
some things you know you were hemmed up
on so like you would like right at the
top of like one of the big things was
like right at the top
of a piece of like loose leaf or
whatever you know like on like the top
margin like whatever the formula or a
[ __ ] whatever type thing then close
that into like the math book in the
textbook so it's sticking out the top
and then throw that on the ground
you see what i'm saying so you can still
read that but that's so it doesn't look
like papers are out sure and then if
they do come over they're like oh put
that paper like oh it's a way i didn't
even
that's crazy i didn't know what it
always feels like it's a little more
open book for kids
unless i'm wrong i don't i mean i'm
basically that's
i'm basing that on absolutely nothing
yeah no i know oh i know yeah yeah um
that well that's what they would always
get me would be uh math would always
trick yeah hit me up because they had
they hit you with that show your work
[ __ ] show your work with the show my
work wait it's a magic trick what the
[ __ ]
i'm giving this away
it ain't 32 dicks we're gonna come see
the show again if i tell you how i did
it
try to record my stand-up sense
um
there was that and then at that same
point we had uh the ti 83 calculator
yeah so kids i didn't know how to do it
but kid like you could put like a note
in there but kids had like the formulas
and like somebody would soup it up for
you give it to the [ __ ] nerd in the
in the front be like yo real tune this
up and he would you know he would put
some whatever in it for you so you could
just like kind of throw all the
functions in or whatever i will say i
never
i never applied any muscle
i might have been a dick to a kid who
wouldn't let me cheat but i never
applied any muscles oh no i was also
fine with it but he might have got like
you might have got like are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah i don't think something like
that um best i ever saw a kid scanned a
sweet tarts wrapper and then four-point
font put all the answers to a test i've
printed it out wrapped it up re-glued it
pretty slick yeah that's the kid who
should just be acing the test if he put
his mind to it you can do that
yeah but it's also like that'll take you
[ __ ] maybe an hour 40 minutes really
he's got graphic designer [ __ ] um
what hey where does he print it
you just print it on like a [ __ ] p
like you would just like type here
equals mc squared whatever whatever and
then tape it back on and then this sits
on your [ __ ] thing that got big well
it's also different like in our
generation the internet was there and
people were like look at this hack or
like it on like what some website
e-bombs world or whatever and you go oh
i have a printer i can [ __ ] do that
so like you didn't have to the ingenuity
wasn't there you could just learn from
other people doing it on the internet i
remember taking tests when i was really
young using chalk
on the paper we know we all had slates i
i remember that real young i feel really
dumb i would like to practice your um oh
yeah to practice writing or something i
hated that chalkboard i hated that
um that was me to willy's thinking about
it i had one what kind of rudimentary
[ __ ] is that
what is this the [ __ ] 1700s
i mean yeah i remember learning cursive
in there we got a [ __ ] white board
over here um got some shortness
long-term goals never had anybody with a
whiteboard
we get an ad schedule or something
that's [ __ ] three months old i gotta
redo that
um then i had a buddy i think i'm going
to mention this i had a buddy who did uh
like record he was like what a pretty
one to be like a rapper or whatever so
we had like recording equipment and he
just recorded
all of the information or like formulas
or whatever it was with an ipod so he
had the
he had he had his hood up and the
headphones in his thing and he just
played his own track of like the formula
is this this is a whatever this is that
jesus yeah
that and then one time i think i said it
we stole a test we snuck into the
teacher's thing and stole a test it was
an animal house
it was a real zack morris vibe
and then i gotta wet my beak so i got it
i went down to the
the uh the library and was like
hey flashed your switchblade missed
i said mr evans needs like whatever 50
copies of this what are you that's
ferris bueller's i know i was kind of
like
wow [ __ ] it already so i was like we
need 50 copies of this and she was she
gave me pushback she's like why would he
give you the test to make a copy oh this
is for 10th grade
make with the make with the papers well
she's the best question
uh and then so she printed me 50 copies
and i sold it for 10 bucks a piece she
didn't go and follow up with the teacher
hey did you ask kevin to mm-hmm
that's how you get away with it yeah
that's how you get away with it said my
name was h foley by the way really you
knew me back then
you're a big fan big fan yeah sunny days
your vibe was probably in the heyday of
your music uh if i was 18
oh you were 28
up here doing it right yeah just got up
here
just a small town boy living in a lonely
world took the midnight train going
anywhere going nowhere gang that's the
show we love you make sure you subscribe
on the youtube page gang and check out
the special and share the special tell a
friend come to a show bring a friend
20 22 baby new tour
it's gonna be a good time hear the trash
we love you peace